the list of numbers a series is actually
a sum you're actually adding up all
those terms in that sequence so I'll
give you an example and I'll show you a
little bit about the formula we're gonna
be working with here today which is S
sub N equals n over 2 times a sub 1 plus
a sub n so let's just do a simple
example I'm sure your teacher is going
to show you a similar example as this so
just to prepare you here say you wanted
to add up all the numbers from 1 to 100
okay that would take a while right so 1
plus 2 Plus 3 plus 4 plus dot dot dot is
96 97 98 okay by this time you'd be
tired right 99 a hundred right but look
what happens here if we add one plus a
hundred together we get 101 right see we
add two plus 99 together what do we get
101 we add three in 98 what do we get
101 how many hundred and ones do you
think we would get if we added up all
the integers from one to a hundred
well if you said 50 you're right because
you're pairing them up two at a time so
in our formula what we did is we added
the first term a sub one which was one
plus the last term which is a sub n this
is a hundred we added those together
when we got a hundred and one okay but
how many hundred ones do we have we have
50 which is a hundred divided by two so
we had we took the number of terms one
hundred divided by two because we were
pairing about two at a time
so what we ended up getting was 50 times
101 and that gives us the sum of all the
numbers from 1 to 100 so that's what the
formula comes from just remember and is
the number of terms a sub 1 is the first
term a sub n is the last term and for
this problem how I would have written it
is a sub 100 sub meaning like subscript
sum of the first hundred terms equals
100 divided by two times the first term
one plus the last term 100 simplify and
you'll get the sum of the first 100
terms pretty neat right okay so now on
the next example what I want to show you
is this sing
see this funny looking a that's the
Greek letter Sigma and what it means is
it means some it just means that you're
adding up all the terms okay you start
at this bottom number this is called the
index here it's I equals four and this
top number is twenty what it means as we
started four we put in four three times
four is 12 plus 2 is 14 plus we go our
work our way up you know sequentially so
the next term would be five we put five
and it's 15 plus two is 17 we put in the
next term which is six that's 18 plus
two is 20 and we work our way up dot dot
to this top term here 20 if we put 20
and we get 3 times 20 is 60 plus 2 is 62
so we're adding up and that's what this
a means the Sigma means it's the
summation notation summation means
you're finding the sum of all these
terms starting at the bottom number I
equals 4 put that in work your way out 5
6 7 8 9 10 all the way up to 20 and then
add up all those terms so it's kind of a
condensed way of writing this whole
series out okay so let's go ahead and
find that sum so we're gonna use our
formula here again there's 20 not
actually 20 terms we're going from 4 to
20 if we were starting at one there
would be 20 but we're starting at 4 now
here's a little trick okay and I'm sure
your teacher will show you this you want
to take 20 minus 4 okay which is 16 but
since we're counting the first term and
the last term we have to add one more so
there's actually 17 terms from 4 to 20
now sometimes students people be
confused by that but just do a smaller
and a simpler example so you take the 5
fingers on your hand how many numbers
are there from 1 to 5 well 5 minus 1 is
4 but you can see you have 5 fingers
right so you have to add one more so
when you count the first and the last
when you subtract like that you just
have to add one more ok so there's
actually 17 terms we're going to use
this formula over here there's 17 terms
we're finding S sub 17 17 divided by 2
the first term we figured out was 14 and
the last term which is what the a sub n
represents
is 62 and so if we do this we get 8.5
and that's going to be 76 and if we
multiply those together we get the sum
of all these terms okay so let's look at
one last example here I'll show you a
little bit more challenging one here
here we have a sequence 2 5 8 11 14 now
by adding addition signs in between all
these terms I just changed it from a
sequence to a series okay and we're
gonna find the sum of the first 20 terms
okay so let's go to our formula and is
20 so we have F sub xx equals 20 divided
by 2 the first term which is 2 plus the
last term oh oh we don't have a last
term so how do we find out what that
last term is well in the previous video
I did on arithmetic sequences remember
we use the formula a sub n a sub n
equals a sub 1 plus D times n minus 1
we're going to use that formula find
that xx terms so the first term is 2 the
common difference is you're adding 3
each time so that's going to be 3 we
want to find the 20th term so n is 20 so
that's 2 plus 3 times 19 which is 57
plus 2 is 59 so if we were to keep going
this last term would be 59 and there we
go we got it so this is going to be 10
times 61 which is 610 and that beats
having to write out you know the first
20 terms and acts adding them all up we
can just use our sum formula so I hope
you're enjoying these videos I hope
you're learning something if you have
questions go ahead and comment below
subscribe to the channel I have more
videos coming for you check out some of
my past videos and let's help you get
better at your math I'll see in the next
video